All right, this is a fun
problem, so it'll get a video
on its own.
I started in the last video,
but I'm going to start over
just so we get it
all in one take.
So they say, in the figure
above, arc SBT is 1/4 of a
circle with center
R and radius 6.
And they actually tell-- they
draw this distance, which is
the radius.
This distance is 6, right?
So this distance would
also be 6, right?
If the length plus the width
of rectangle ABCR is 8-- so
this is ABCR.
So the length plus
the width is 8.
So let's call this
L and this is W.
Actually, this should be-- well,
it doesn't matter, this
should be height,
but whatever.
We know that these two
sides are equal to 8.
So we know that L plus
W is equal to 8.
Fair enough.
Then the perimeter of the shaded
region is-- that's this
perimeter right here, so there's
a lot of pieces to it.
So let's start with
what I would call
the low hanging fruit.
So the low hanging fruit,
in my opinion, is the
length of this arc.
Arc SBT.
What's the length of that?
Well, it's going to be 1/4 the
circumference of the entire
circle, right?
Because this arc represents--
what we drew is 1/4 of the
circle, so this length is
going to be 1/4 of the
circumference.
So the length of the
circumference-- so the
circumference of, let me see,
the circumference of the
circle, is what?
It's 2 pi r.
r is 6, right?
So 2 pi times 6, is
equal to 12 pi.
If the circumference of the
circle is 12 pi, then we could
call the length of the arc,
right-- let's call this LA--
the length of the arc
is going to be what?
It's going to be 1/4
the circumference
of the whole circle.
1/4 times 12 pi is
equal to 3 pi.
Good enough.
Now what else can we
try to figure out?
Well, the second lowest hanging
fruit is actually the
length of this line.
Which you're probably saying,
well, they give me no
information, maybe I have to
use the Pythagorean theorem
with W and L, but it's really
just a visual trick, because
I'll tell you that you could
actually just look at this
graph and figure out what the
length from A to C is.
And I'll give you a hint.
What is the length
from R to B?
What is that length?
Well isn't R to B a radius
of the circle?
Right?
It's going from the center
to the edge of
circle, so it's a radius.
So RB has length 6.
And RB is a diagonal of this
rectangle just like AC is, so
they're symmetric, so this is
also going to be equal to 6.
And you could look at it a bunch
of different ways, you
could say that W squared
plus L squared is
equal to this, AC squared.
Well, W squared, this is W as
well, right, you could also
say that W squared plus
L squared is equal
to this side squared.
So that's why they're
equal to each other.
So we know length of AC is
equal to 6, as well.
Right?
We figured out that.
So we have two pieces left.
We just have that piece,
and that piece.
What's the length
of this piece?
Well, this whole
distance is 6.
We figured that out because
that's a radius.
And this piece is L, right?
That's L.
So that piece is 6 minus L.
Similarly, what's this piece?
By the same logic, that's
6 minus W, right?
This is W, the whole
thing is 6, so this
leftover is 6 minus W.
So if we want the perimeter of
this entire shaded region,
it's this perimeter of this
brown arc, which is 3 pi.
So let me say, perimeter
is equal to 3 pi.
Plus the length of AC, plus 6.
Plus this piece,
plus 6 minus L.
plus 6 minus W.
And let's simplify that a bit.
So let's see, that equals 3
pi, and then we have three
6's, so plus 18, minus
L, minus W.
And this is the same thing as
3 pi plus 18 minus L plus W.
Fascinating.
And really, I kind of just
bumbled my way here.
You know the problem is
solvable, and that's better
than most mathematicians have
going for them, and so you
just kind of have to bumble away
with whatever information
they give you.
The real trick here, I think, is
recognizing that AC is the
same length as RB.
But once you get to this point,
you have to now employ
the second trick.
You have to realize that minus
L minus W, well that looks a
lot like this L plus
W up here.
And this is really kind of what
separates the adults from
the children, I guess.
So we know that L plus W is 8,
so just substitute here, 8.
So the perimeter is 3 pi,
plus 18, minus 8.
That equals 3 pi plus 10,
and that is choice B.
That was exciting.
I'll see you in the
next section.